[Music]
there's one thing I know about the world
it's not the little things that matter
it's the tiny things do you want cheese
yes Jesus my life my name is Bella and
this is how I met Lucas see they seem to
really like you maybe that's a sign her
home supposed to be don't choose shoes
don't you shoot that one was his
favorite over the years we did
everything together
girl we chased a squirrel
we went to work we even played a game
called doctor doctor doctor game
everything all right yeah life with
Lucas was the best but when he wasn't
around I missed him so much it's--that's
were like a squirrel squirrel squirrel
[Music]
duh looks like she needs help
away the church I was very far from home
but I knew Lucas was waiting for me and
I had to go and find him
[Music]
even better than a tiny piece of cheese
we all face things that are hard the
only thing that gets us through it are
the special people in our lives and I
was never going to stop searching until
I found mine
[Music]
that dog saved his life
[Music]